STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
ONE OF THE BRILLIANT THINGS
ABOUT WATCHING PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN SITUATIONS LIKE TONIGHT
TOWNHALL IS THAT HE’S SO
TRANSPARENT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS WHEN HE’S
TALKING ABOUT THE MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WITMER.
SHE SAYING WE DON’T HAVE THE
SWABS WE NEED, THE TESTING
THAT SHE NEEDS.
>> LOOK, LOOK, WE HAD A PHONE
CALL FIVE DAYS AGO WITH THE
GOVERNORS.
I WAS IN THE CALL WITH VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE WHO HAS
DONE A GREAT JOB.
HE’S THE HEAD OF THE COMMITTEE
ON THE TASK FORCE.
EVERY GOVERNOR THERE ASKED ME,
WHAT YOU NEED.
NOT ONE GOVERNOR NEEDED
ANYTHING.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU SEE
HER IN THE SUNDAY I WATCHED
THAT WE SHOULD GET THIS WE
SHOULD GET THAT, SHOULDN’T SHE
GET BACK TO RUNNING HER STATE
PROPERLY.
SHE SHOULDN’T BROUGHT ABOUT ON
A PHONE CALL.
>> OKAY, SO I LOVE THAT.
THAT IS JUST CLASSIC TRUMP.
THERE’S A COUPLE PARTS TO
THAT.
FIRST OF ALL HE’S JUST SO
DIRECT.
YOU DON’T SEE THAT FROM NORMAL
POLITICIANS.
THEY JUST NEVER SAY LET ME
TELL YOU ABOUT THE ACTUAL
PHONE CALL WE HAD, BUT THE
POINT I REALLY WANTED TO GET
YOUR REACTION TO SARAH BECAUSE
IT CAME UP IN ANOTHER QUESTION
DURING TONIGHT WHICH WAS FROM
A REALLY STRONG TRUMP
SUPPORTER WHO SAID WERE GREAT,
WE LOVE YOU WE THINK YOU’RE
DOING A GREAT JOB BUT WERE NOT
SURE WE LIKE ALL THIS
AGGRESSIVE LANGUAGE EITHER
WITH THE PRESS OR THE
GOVERNORS.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THAT SARAH
WHEN HE’S JUST REALLY HITTING
BACK AGAINST GOVERNOR AND
OTHER GOVERNORS.
WHAT YOU THINK.
>> I THINK THE PEOPLE EXPECT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING TO
STOP THEM FROM VOTING FOR HIM,
THOSE WHO SUPPORT HIM IN
NOVEMBER, COME NOVEMBER, AND
WHAT MAKES THE DIFFERENCE HERE
STEVE IS THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISN’T AFRAID
TO EXPRESS HOW HE FEELS AND
THAT’S PRETTY MUCH WHAT EVERY
AMERICAN IS FEELING SO IF HE’S
TALKING ABOUT GOVERNOR WITMER
AND SHE ALL OF A SUDDEN IS
COMPLAINING AND POLITICIZING
AFTER HAVING A PHONE CALL WITH
HIM HE’S JUST AN ESSAY IT LIKE
IT IS WHICH IS ACTUALLY VERY
REFRESHING.
I UNDERSTAND SOMETIMES PEOPLE
CAN BE PUT OFF BY THIS BECAUSE
THEY’RE USED TO POLITICIANS
BEING POLITICIANS, BUT THE
REASON PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ELECTED IS BECAUSE HE CONNECTS
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
WE KNOW THAT HE IS TELLING THE
TRUTH AND HE’S ACTUALLY
FIGHTING FOR US BECAUSE HE’S
NOT AFRAID TO SAY WHAT’S ON
HIS MIND AND I THINK THAT
MAKES THE REAL DIFFERENCE HERE.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT, IS MET.
THAT’S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHANGES, ASIDE FROM ALL THE
POLICY CHANGES IS THIS
COMPLETELY REINVENTED THE WAY
PEOPLE SEE THEIR LEADERS.
>> SURE, AND LET’S JUST TAKE
THE OBVIOUS, THE GOVERNOR OF
MICHIGAN IS AUDITIONING TO BE
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND SO WHETHER
THINGS ARE GOING WELL OR
POORLY REGARDING THE FEDERAL
CORONATION, SHE EXIST TO BE A
THEATRICAL CRITIC OF THE
PRESIDENT REGARDLESS OF THE
SUPPORT BEING PROVIDED AND IF
SHE’S HAVING PROBLEMS WITH
TESTING, MAYBE THOSE ARE HER
CHALLENGES AND EXECUTION, NOT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
HERE IN FLORIDA IT WAS JUST ON
FRIDAY THAT GOVERNOR DESANTIS
AND I WERE SETTING UP A MOBILE
TESTING FACILITY TO BUILD
CONFIDENCE WHERE PEOPLE COULD
DRIVE THROUGH AND GET VERY
RAPID RESULTS, WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR SO
WHEN THOSE FRONTLINE
INDUSTRIES, PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
KNOW THAT WHEN THEY GO INTO A
RESTAURANT OR MAYBE A RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENT THAT THEY ARE
DEALING WITH EMPLOYEES WHO
HAVE HIGH HEALTH STANDARDS AND
WHO ARE SAFE.
I THINK ALLOWING THE STATES TO
BE THE LABORATORIES OF THOSE
INNOVATIONS AND REALLY PUSH
FORWARD WITH WAYS TO BUILD
THAT CONFIDENCE WILL
ULTIMATELY RESTORE OUR ECONOMY
MORE QUICKLY AND I’M SORRY IF
THEY JUST HAVEN’T THOUGHT OUT
THE ANSWERS IN MICHIGAN QUITE
YET.
WE ARE DOING PRETTY WELLIN
FLORIDA.
>> I THINK THAT IS SUCH A DEEP
AND TRUE POINT LISA CAN WE GET
THIS, IT’S LIKE A MANTRA FROM
THE TRUMP CRITICS IN THE
MEDIA.
WERE TESTING, BUT IT’S JUST SO
UNTRUE IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR
SCALE OF THE ESCALATION IN
TERMS OF THE PRODUCTION
CAPACITY.
THIS IS AGAIN SOMETHING THAT
PRESIDENT SPOKE TO TONIGHT
AGAIN WITH ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
HOW TRANSPARENT HE CAN BE.
THIS TIME IT WAS A CALL FROM
KIM DAVID.
LET’S HAVE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE THE BEST TESTING
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
I SPENT THE WEEKEND AT CAMP
DAVID SPEAKING TO AND, HEADS
OF OTHER COUNTRY WHO ARE
DESPERATE FOR OUR VENTILATORS
AND WE NOW HAVE SO MANY
VENTILATORS, A MONTH AGO
THAT’S ALL THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
THE TEAM OF PEOPLE THAT DID
THIS JOB, IT WAS PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST MOBILIZATION SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
>> THIS IS A POINT THAT I JUST
THINK THEY’RE NOT GIVING HIM
ANY CREDIT FOR WHICH IS THE
SPEED WITH WHICH THEY, IT’S
NOT THAT EASY WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE DETAILS
OF HOW TESTING WORKS.
YOU JUST SORT OF TURN IT ON
AND NOW BY FAR THE BIGGEST IN
THE WORLD, THE VENTILATOR
PROBLEM IS JUST BASICALLY, NO
ONE EVEN TALKS ABOUT IT
ANYMORE.
I DON’T SEE THE PRESIDENT
GOING TO GET ANY CREDIT FROM
HIS CRITICS FOR WHAT HE JUST
DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF
INDUSTRIAL MOBILIZATION TO
MEET THIS MOMENT.
LISA, DO YOU AGREE.
>> 100%.
HE NEVER IS.
WE KNOW THIS AND COVERING THE
MEDIA, WE KNOW THIS AND
COVERING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, HE NEVER GETS
CREDIT FOR ANYTHING AND JUST
THE SBA CLEARING RED TAPE SO
YOU CAN GET TEST MARKET AND
THEN WE CAN ALSO LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE THERAPEUTICS AND
PEOPLE USING THEM UNDER
COMPASSIONATE USE AS WELL AND
I THINK THE CONVERSATION
TONIGHT IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THIS CONVERSATION WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE FOR THE
LONGEST TIME THE DOMINATING
QUESTION HAS BEEN, IS IT SAFE
TO REOPEN THE ECONOMY.
ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
REOPENING THE ECONOMY.
WE SHOULD ALSO BE ASKING
OURSELVES WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF REMAINING SHOT
AND REMAINING CLOSE
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE ECONOMIC CALAMITY PILING
UP.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MENTAL
HEALTH ASPECT OF THIS AND EVEN
ONE NATIONAL HOTLINE ALONE, A
NINE 100% INCREASE IN CALLS
AND YOU LOOK AROUND THE WORLD
AND 130 MILLION PEOPLE COULD
BE PUSHED TO THE BRINK OF
STARVATION BECAUSE OF
DISRUPTIONS IN THE GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN AND FOOD AND ALSO
BECAUSE OF THE CORONAVIRUS OR
YOU LOOK AT POLAND, FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND 40% COULD
POTENTIALLY CLOSE THEIR DOORS
FOREVER IN THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS.
OR EVEN THE HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF NONESSENTIAL,
NOT BEING ALLOWED TO GO
FORWARD BECAUSE OF THE
PRIORITY FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
YOU LOOK AT ALL THESE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
ISOLATION POLICIES, OF THE
SHUTDOWN, AND AS IT STARTS TO
PILE UP WE NEED TO BE LOOKING
AT THE TOTALITY OF THE
SITUATION AS WE ARE MAKING
THESE DECISIONS MOVING
FORWARD, AND REALLY UNTIL
RECENTLY THAT HASN’T
HAPPENED.
STEVE: EXACTLY RIGHT.
I SO AGREE WITH YOU LISA.
I SAID THIS ON TWITTER EARLIER
IN THE WEEK, WHICH IS WE
REALLY ARE SICK OF HEARING
FROM ALL THESE LEADERS ABOUT
HOW THERE FOLLOWING THE DATA
ON KEEPING THE SHUTDOWN WHEN
THEY’RE ACTUALLY GIVING US
ZERO DATA ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH COSTS OF KEEPING THE